the Joe Rogan experience tear and it's
five hours from Cleveland so wasn't it
wasn't a quick chop late for the food
poisoning sketchy so you know it sucks
it was all had an end four or five times
in my life it's never never good that's
the second time the first time I had it
was in college was the worst thing ever
it was way worse this was both ends this
is when your mouth and back door when
you're it's like a cartoon ahead in
college from movie theater popcorn what
that's real [ __ ] movie that's real [ __ ]
food here's how we knew we me and this
other dude we had totally different
meals all day and this other friend of
ours too and long story short whatever
we both woke up sick at the same time
like in the middle of the night and we
had asked when I went to the doctor
finally the next day because I was sick
all day and the doctor was like would
you eat I detailed and he goes oh yeah
sometimes the butter can be spoiled or
rotten Oh actual butter yeah oh maybe
that's why they use that fake ass butter
oh yeah which is that fake gas burner
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is movie popcorn
theater butter made out of it's not real
butter because most places don't have
real but Jamie's laughing at my
sicknesses no movie popcorn what do you
think it is it's like it was it was
weird yeah wonderfull Avery oil butter
flavor okay that's not butter
what is that [ __ ] well they say bad
that stuff is for you people used to
think margins the way to go like if you
butters pear before you have some
margarine margarine non-dairy it's me
know it's [ __ ] horrible for you but
all processed oils you know they're
final now from those fake meat burgers
they've wrestled rats they're giving
them liver cancer pull up what would it
would it would the study was yeah yeah
yeah one of those is beyond meat or
impossible meat or not really meat
whatever the [ __ ] it is just yeah not me
but looks like meat we're trying to make
it look like me its processed oils with
grill marks on it why did I do that [ __ ]
it's mostly oils yeah it's like oils
from vegetables it's very lot of soy and
[ __ ] like that
that's like those processed vegetable
oils are terrible for you yeah you know
what's good for you olive oil that's a
good vegetable oil avocado oil is good
for you but
all that other [ __ ] like canola and all
that stuff well [ __ ] there's my
question is it because it's not
naturally occurring feeding studies
suggests the impossible burger may not
be safe to eat
scroll down this is GMO science it says
hold on a second
make the little are rats fed gym rats
what do you do make it bigger that's
just going on rats
sundered stop stop moving go back Jesus
Jamie it stopped go back go back that's
on back oh no it's not there thank you
thank you rats fed the genetic know the
[ __ ] text there buddy rats fed the
genetically modified yeast derived
protein soy whoa say that word LaHaye
gamma globin no the jicama glow but hate
my globin
it sounds like an Irishman Danny magma
globin he's a good boy he's very key
ingredient developed unexplained changes
in weight gain and significant signs of
toxicity and signs of toxicity why did I
put the word significant in there wasn't
in there I felt right it did I'm an
editor okay unexplained changes in
weight gain and signs of toxicity and it
said the impossible burgers a
plant-based burger the key ingredient
which is a protein called so late a
heckuva heckuva SL h derived from
genetically modified yeast a rat feeding
study commissioned by the manufacturer
impossible foods found that rats fed SLE
each developed unexplained changes of
weight gain as well as changes in the
blood that can indicate that the onset
of inflammation or kidney disease as
well as possible signs of anemia holy
[ __ ] yeah impossible foods dismissed
these statistically significant effects
as non adverse or having no toxic
already intense it's so funny you can
just dismiss things they just make it a
real study and they're like not real
well they're dismissing it because it's
not convenient it's real simple I mean
the do rat studies doesn't necessarily
mean it transfers to people but that
stuff isn't okay what's the ingredients
let's let's find out what the [ __ ]
it's not the only thing that I've read
I've read things by actual nutritionist
they're saying look you want to be on a
plant-based diet you should eat real
foods you can eat healthy on a
plant-based diet you can eat real
vegetables and avocado and you know
there's plenty of good stuff to eat
coconut oils all this stuff is healthy
for you but we you start making [ __ ]
look like meat that's when [ __ ] gets
squirrely because you're finding all
kinds of your your they're adding all
sorts of processed food why'd you take
that off the screen
I don't wanna be distracting while
you're talking oh no that's okay so what
the [ __ ] is in there top five
ingredients calories four ounce serving
which is pretty skimpy clocks in to 240
calories that's in the range of a beef
burger depending on fat content and
cholesterol the impossible contains no
cholesterol to compare a regular beef
patty contains about 80 milligrams grow
up
scroll up scroll up scroll up scroll up
fat 14 grams includes 8 grams of
saturated fat which generally considered
less healthy than unsaturated fat that's
not true
it's it's entirely dependent upon the
source and it's entirely dependent upon
Mekhi you're eating like what you're
eating
yeah like the idea that saturated fat is
bad for you this has all been debunked
this is comparable to a beef burger
mostly due to the coconut oil which is
healthy for you [ __ ] this year the
impossible replaced a portion of the
coconut oil which is the highest and
saturated fat goddamnit
with son fala aura which is way shittier
for you which is an unsaturated fat god
damn this you know talking to
nutritionists on this podcast has been
so enlightening but so confusing well
you see the way that people still want
to eat low fat you know and they like
they don't understand like fats are
important your [ __ ] needs them they're
good for your brain they're good for
everything omega-3 omega-6 is that was
the revolution of like I remember as a
kid everything became in like the ladies
and 90s everything was lower fat but it
was higher sugar content right so it was
just like less fat less fat but they
were just increasing the sugar it was
like 1% milk that's the biggest joke
when they're like put sugar in it less
fat yeah but they substituted it with
tons of [ __ ] sugar because it tastes
terrible yeah it tastes like [ __ ]
without the fat all those
monsters have put low-fat milk in their
coffee whoo the face of [ __ ] who are you
the trick got tricked
they got tricked by this idea that
you're supposed to have low fat find out
pull up something
what is the impossible burger healthy is
it healthy well here's because here's
the thing they were pushed that article
obviously was siding with the impossible
burg because they cited three four items
and it was like soy protein coconut in
something else they don't really tell
you how to processes that they make
those that's the thing they won't say
well here's how we derive these things
and [ __ ] process I was gonna say
before I even look this up I don't think
that they're even marketing as being
healthier it's just an alternative you
know for me for people that really still
want to eat it yeah exactly
right but is it healthy for ya I don't
think that there's nothing bothering ya
it's probably less healthy for you than
a [ __ ] McDonald's cheeseburger which
is barely meat anyway
[Applause]